house i'm looking at you sir are you
gonna give me a zebra or a horse i don't
know let's check it out
on this house md medical review and huge
thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring this
video
what are you kidding me tub of good
there's gotta be over six bills you
ain't gonna lift it with a couple of
blankets no this is time to write the
einstein
yeah just just roll him off what he's
already dead ain't like he's gonna feel
it this is actually a situation that
some of my paramedic friends discussed
with me
about legitimately having trouble
getting humans
outside of their homes into the
ambulance and into the er
there's even been times that i've heard
them talk about injuring themselves
bringing patients out of their homes
because they were perhaps overweight or
obese or
perhaps their environment wasn't safe
all right one
two
come on man me you're the killer boss
the kid wasn't me
oh whoa it wasn't me either
don't look at me is the patient alive
did no one check for a pulse trust me
skin's cold pupils are fixed and dilated
he's not breathing he's got a pulse
he's not dead if he has a pulse 46 year
old guy in a
coma doesn't appear to be anything wrong
with him except for the fact that he
weighs over 600 pounds
who says that who who talks about a
patient's weight like that
and says there's probably nothing wrong
do you know that do you know his history
he can't even give you his full history
there's no way you could have results
this quickly
like at least get an echocardiogram
blood sugar's normal
cholesterol is lower than mine toxic
screens clean no sign of trauma
sure there wasn't a mix up with the lab
three times i'm glad that they rechecked
because if a clinical picture
meaning what a patient looks like
behaves like or symptoms are like
don't match the labs you should be
rechecking those labs too many times
i've had that happen
recheck the labs and find out they're
completely normal or the other way
completely abnormal so i always like to
keep
laboratory error in the back of my mind
or in the front of my mind the forefront
of my mind my mind there's nothing
abnormal in the eeg or the neurological
exam
who gets an eg when a patient just rolls
in
it's too soon you should get a cat scan
see what the lungs are like
get an echo see what the anatomy of the
heart is like
you should see what the digestive system
is like with a cat scan
when a patient comes in and you don't
know what's going on you have to throw
all the tests at the patient in order to
understand what's going on you need to
check for substance abuse you need to
check
for toxic metabolites complete metabolic
panel the complete blood count look at
all these values
and not just jump to conclusions i mean
like doing an eeg seems like
the 50th step and they've skipped over 1
through 49. improperly prepared puffer
fish can have toxins that could cause a
coma and might not show up on the talk
screen
and if it was a puffer fish he'd be dead
in six to eight hours time so he's been
in a coma at least 24.
how do people know this fact about
puffer fish
come on foreman you didn't know that you
googled it
he googled it this is ridiculous a
person shouldn't be able to eat
themselves into oblivion and then just
expect everyone to pull out the stops to
fix everything what are we supposed to
do
refuse treatment to anyone who's obese
come on give me a break this guy's an
obese he's not even morbidly obese he's
suicidal
people who attempt suicide get treated
when you have non-compliant diabetic
stone
wait non-compliant diabetics do get
treated i don't know why he said that
and patients who
are addicted to food or perhaps have uh
an emotional issue that is causing them
to overeat and become
600 pounds or perhaps have a medical
condition that's causing them to gain
this much weight shouldn't be judged
like you can't be a doctor and be this
judgy and be successful as a clinician
you should do an lp with
neurosyphilis it's not syphilis how do
you know whatever he has is connected to
his gut now what's below it
mra his brain look for clots she said
that the blood was drawn three times
in that time they couldn't check for
syphilis
one two three
not gonna lie this is a true challenge
for hospital and hospital systems
when patients can't fit in the equipment
that's why we are trying to create newer
equipment that is more
uh capable in handling patients of all
different sizes and shapes
weeds clats influx i don't see any edema
either
so what do we do now an lp even if it's
not an std a fever boys towards some
sort of infection
i'm not sure we can do an lp on a guy
his size
did they get a chest x-ray like if you
elise had a chest x-ray you could do
that portable you could do it right in
the bed
you could see if that there was a lung
infection you could rule that out check
the urine see if there's a urinary tract
infection with the pylonephritis going
up to the kidneys like why aren't they
talking about the most common things
this show is all about zebras not horses
remember that saying
when you hear hoof beats think horses
not zebras doesn't mean you forget the
zebras just means you think the horse is
first
back to morehouse in just a second but
first i want to talk to you about
nordvpn
a service that protects your internet
connection and privacy online something
i really like about nordvpn
is securing your traffic on public wi-fi
keeping things like your account logins
and banking info
safe and you can run it up to six
devices at once on every major platform
a benefit of using nordvpn is accessing
content from anywhere say you're in a
country that doesn't have a streaming
option for house md if you use nordvpn
you can set your location to a country
that does have access to house and
stream as much as you want
it's honestly so easy and it just takes
one click go to
dr nordvpn.com or use coupon code
doctormike remember doctor is spelled
out to get a two-year plan plus a bonus
gift
with a huge discount and security of a
30-day money-back guarantee
all right let's get back to morehouse
calm down man calm down
we still have no idea why he was in the
coma to begin with or why he woke up
what if it is hormones acute adrenal
insufficiency could cause a temporary
coma
it can and also a thyroid storm can
cause a coma although a thyroid storm
would probably come with a rapid heart
rate
also not weight gain if you have a
hyperactive thyroid
although if you have an underactive
thyroid followed by thyroid storm which
can happen because the thyroid
even in like certain conditions like
hashimoto's and graves disease
sometimes it flips on and off between
hyper and hypothyroid it's not always so
clearly defined
especially in the beginning of the onset
of disease
to later stages of disease we should do
a full std panel and check his genitals
for shankers well first of all you
should have checked him for shankers
beforehand and you should have done a
full sed panel beforehand it's like the
cheapest test you can do
if you're talking about all these mris
that you're breaking costing millions of
dollars
the 300 std panel would have been worth
it don't you think
are you having any problems with your
vision no i have nystagmus i've had it
since
birth i'm fine you're not fine you're in
a coma for two days there's something
wrong with you
was something wrong with me now i'm
better now i'd like to go home
the patient can always leave like if he
can think about the consequences if the
patient can
verbalize those consequences and it's
safe for them to leave in that sense
they can choose to leave they will leave
against medical advice which is an ama
but it's within their rights it's
patient autonomy wait let us take you
all the way outside
i'm fine uh it doesn't matter it's
hospital rules oh screw the rules i've
been on my back for four days
i need the exercise right george come on
let us just take you to the taxi don't
worry
i may not be able to climb everest but i
can walk
[Music]
first of all if a patient has not gotten
up
since he's been admitted to the hospital
would get a pt evaluation to see
if he's capable of walking on his own
and if he's not he cannot safely go home
alone he would at least need to go to a
sub-acute rehab stay
where he could learn how to walk on his
own and take care of himself because if
a patient can't get up and walk you're
essentially setting them up for failure
by sending them home
i think we should focus on the coma in
the favor we have a rather large piece
of tempered glass that begs to differ
i just mean it's not connected how could
you possibly know because i did it
i didn't think he should be discharged
so i gave him three grams of benaton
what hospital is this she drugged the
patient so he wouldn't leave
oh my god
don't poison your patients even if you
think it's right for them because you
are not god
what would happen to her medical license
lost we'll do it in order they find out
medical review committee
medical board suspension followed by
medical board revaluation followed by
loss of medical license either
temporarily or forever depending on
how angry the patient is prior
situations etc etc
lawyer up it can't be chagas he's never
been outside the country
his stomach has the food we eat no
longer comes from america's heartland it
comes from south america's deforested
jungle land
where lettuce now grows and lettuce
picker is now poop get a sample of his
csf how are you gonna get a sample of
this cerebrospinal fluid that's going to
be tough
you want to drill a hole in my head it's
got to be
something other than a parasite i buy my
produce it's the best market in town
and i always wash it leafy vegetables
can set contaminated water through the
roots right into the plant i've never
heard this
this sounds far-fetched but i hope they
research this
please tell me this is a neurosurgeon
doing this not like foreman
it's forming oh my god these they're all
neurosurgeons infectious disease
specialists family medicine doctors
cardiologists they run mri machines
all cramp what what'd you do nothing
what's wrong i can't i can't see
vision's blurry or you've lost
i didn't lose it you took it from george
calm down i can't speak
this is actually why patients are kept
awake during some neuro procedures
because
in case you do touch something you want
to know right away so that you don't
continue doing damage in that area
blindness plus coma says diabetes
no blood sugar urine dipstick and
hemoglobin a1c are normal we're normal
when you test it spin it out of a coma
whatever's going on is waxing and waning
that's not true because the hemoglobin
a1c gives you an average of the blood
sugars over the last three months so it
doesn't mean it was normal today
it could be different tomorrow it still
will give you the average of the last
three months so i don't agree with house
here
i am not diabetic sooner you drink this
the sooner i get to go waste my time
with something else
get the hell off of me no dessert till
you finish your dinner
such a classic house situation where
he's just losing his mind fighting a
patient
go wait his liver's failing now he's
jaundiced what's happening get x-rays of
his hands
tell him that lung cancer is in no way
connected to obesity uh you don't think
he'll realize we're lying
you're not lung cancer's got nothing to
do with it about him
having lung cancer he didn't notice his
fingers
i noticed they were fat you should have
pissed them off he would have grabbed
you i mean you would have felt the bones
they're not just fat they're clubbed
[Music]
this is the first x-ray they're getting
are you joking
he was in a coma in the icu and they're
just getting an x-ray now
oh they're getting an x-ray of his hand
i thought this is the first chest x-ray
they're getting
your tests were positive
you have a small cell lung carcinoma it
caused a perineoplastic neurologic
syndrome perineoplastic basically means
that as a result of having this tumor it
secreted hormones that have
altered the way that his body behaves
it's
inoperable but there are radiation
treatments available
[Music]
they might give you a few more months i
never smoked
not all lung cancer cases are caused by
smoking some are caused by asbestos
i would ask if he had any questions at
that point i mean you're just delivering
a life-changing diagnosis
you spend 10 seconds and you leave i
think that's kind of cold
check out the harsh reality of being 800
plus pounds here
click it check it out as always stay
happy and healthy
you